Louie cat you know Louie cats maybe I do
you know the we cats I don't know who's
miss scheduling the calls bottle Oh
Louie hi
you're on my podcast run out too by the
way Yeah right now you are yeah
[Music]
so Louie cats on is a comic he moved to
New York and now do you live here now
like what do you mean kind of why are
you in LA you show when you [ __ ] move
there in the first place I was like why
the [ __ ] you're moving this kid is so
[ __ ] funny you know that bit you know
I still do that bit sometimes that you
help me right which is that what down
syndrome people making love joke yeah
when they make love they make up their
own moves they touch butts for three
minutes
love it right what one the breast goes
in the armpit like that one guy get like
that it's also you're doing very well
though I saw you on that Comedy Central
storytelling show I've seen other things
so congratulations Louis I'm sure you
have better things going on but let's
let's get together soon
[Music]
yeah it's called Tiger belly it's pretty
popular okay good
Louie cats October 26 new album great
birthday gift
all right it's my birthday today Judy's
can just say happy birthday or no no
thank you thank you bye Louie okay
that's it now what we didn't plan
he's so a guy who bought it on the right
time he got to play right now
Louie Katz is legitimately [ __ ] a
funny as [ __ ] cats he's so talented
[Music]